vor gut
Kurzer stream heute ich habe bloß zeit bis 22 uhr also wie immer fast
Fast erste auto hast du nicht geschafft
Post
Ich erzähle euch gleich was
und zwar
Wie unfähig manche hersteller schon wieder sind
Ich habe mir eine fitness uhr gekauft wobei erzähle ich erzähle ich euch gleich
Wenn der stream angelaufen ist
Chat muss chat muss noch hohen eq erreichen das stimmt wohl zumal der zweite achte ist
Zweite achte heißt es ist heute ganz viele IQ points die frei sind
Habe ich so gehört
Leute morgen kommt ballos geht 3
Ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch es wurden ja schon überall im internet lobeshymnen auf das game gesungen
Aber ich bin skeptisch
Ich bin aus zwei gründen skeptisch so also
der erste grund ist
Ja ja wort die zahlte silver dankeschön für den zapp
Ich habe gehört auf in wackeln ist ziemlicher schlamm dieses jahr
So dass die wohl irgendwelche fahrzeuge schon mit dem kran überhaupt auf dem parkplatz auf den campingplatz stellen mussten
Also
Weiß nicht ob es da wie gut das funktioniert ach so okay
Dann anderes fest also ballos geht 3 also es gibt ja schon
Mein herz hat das irgendwie komisch okay es gibt ja es gibt der riesen lobes hymnen jetzt schon ich glaube sogar die
Gamestar hat letztens ein video gemacht so nach dem motto dass das ultimative
Rollenspielerlebnis oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung
Ja
So zumindest ihr setzt setzt setzt das rollenspiel zu hohen maßstäbe und sowas
zumindest
Ich freue mich mega auf das game
Ich bin aber skeptisch
Ob ballos geht 3 wirklich so einen sonnen also ich habe keine zweifel
Ich habe keine zweifel oder wenig zweifel dass sie das hinbekommen die spielwelt gut zu bauen ich habe auch keine zweifel dass sie es hinbekommen
Irgendwie eine halbwegs brauchbare story hin zu hin zu hin zu zimmern
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss ballos geht war jetzt noch nie das mega krasse story game der zweite teil hat eine ziemlich coole story
Im prinzip ging es aber nur um irgendwelche mehr zusammengefasst um irgendwelche wie kommt man das denn so emo elfen im endeffekt
Aber war schon immer gut als das kriegen die bestimmt auch also es gibt zwei punkte
Wo ich wo ich wirklich bedenken habe war ballos geht 3 ob sie es ob ob das wirklich so taugt und zwar
Das erste ist der das ist der stil an sich
Guckt euch divinity original sin 2 an und guckt euch mal early access gameplay von ballos geht 3 an
Wenn ich es richtig hart haben wollt guckt ihr euch early early access gameplay von ballos geht 3 an da sieht man nämlich dass es im
Endeffekt divinity original sin 2 ist mit forgotten realms setting
So und auch generell vom stil her
Und auch mit den ganzen also mit mit mit explosiven fessern und
Irgendwelchen bodeneffekten und sowas das ist schon sehr
original sin
Like ob ob das in den dungeons und dragons game passt gerade gerade als nachfolger von ballos geht
Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher
Dezent mag das okay sein aber wie ich was ich bei early access gesehen hat da stehen an jeder ecke irgendwelche explosiven fesser rum und sonst was
Ja also das ist quasi divinity original sin 2.5 mit dungeons und dragons setting also kommt mir das zumindest vom stil hervor
Es gibt es also es gibt ja prinzipiell auch
Nennen wir es mal
boden area effekte
Bei den spells in dungeons und dragons fünfte fünfte edition da gibt es zum beispiel
So gaswolken die man dann verteilen kann mit mit irgendwelchen anderen spells und sowas das steht zumindest so im regelwerk drin
Aber so wirklich viele bodeneffekte wie das divinity original sin 2 hatte gibt es da eigentlich nicht also da bin ich ein bisschen
Bisschen skeptisch ob das ganze das dazu die ganze aufmachung und der stil wirklich zu einem ballos g3 passt
Das ist der erste das erste bedenken was ich habe und das zwar das ist vielleicht gar nicht so wild ja also
Ich weiß ich komme ein bisschen darauf an wie gut sie das regelwerk umgesetzt haben letztendlich
Das eigentliche problem was ich für mich sehe ist man hat bloß vier playable characters
Und das ist zu wenig
Doch das ist zu wenig
Vierer party size ist doof sechser party size ist so viel besser
Sechser party size ist allein schon aus dem grund besser weil du nicht gezwungen bist du bist ja gezwungen bestimmte sachen mitzunehmen
Und das ist einfach nicht flexibel genug eine vierer party size
Sechser party size war optimal mehr muss es nicht sein sie müssen nicht
Sachen machen wie ein dark mit 8er party oder sowas wobei das mmo game war
Aber vierer party size ich weiß nicht ob das so geil ist
Es ist eigentlich relativ
Klar was du
mitnehmen musst
Naja ich bin mal gespannt ich bin mal gespannt wie sie es hingekriegt haben aber ich meinte mindestens eine fünfer party size hätten sie machen
Sollen ich war mir ist klar warum sie das nicht gemacht haben weil divinity original sin auch eine vierer party size hatte
das erste schon
Und das zweite auch dementsprechend glaube ich haben die schlicht und ergreifend da wollten sie keine experimente machen ja
Triffts glaub ich am besten aber ich bin aber passt nicht so richtig
Sechser party size wäre optimal gewesen
Ja richtig krasser weep stream hier immer
Und da bin ich gespannt ob das taucht
Ich werde mir das auf jeden fall morgen holen
Und aber ich werde ich werde nicht streben ich werde das für mich spielen und
Dann mal gucken
Ja ein weiterer punkt ist man muss ja wohl wenn man die volle story haben will einen der vorgefertigten charakters spielen
Und kann glaube ich einen eigenen machen aber ich glaube viele dialog optionen und sowas sind anscheinend gelockt je nachdem ob man einen
Primate charakter nimmt oder nicht da bin ich aber nicht sicher ob ich das richtig verstanden habe und mal gucken also
Ich gehe davon aus dass es ein ziemlich gutes game wird ob es baldur skate wird in dem sinne ich
Ich sehe es bis jetzt noch nicht aber ich lasse mich gern eines besseren belehren
So jetzt kann ich euch mal was erzählen und zwar ich habe mir eine fitness uhr gekauft
Ja ist vielleicht eine bessere idee gehe ich auch mal von aus
Also ich habe mir was da bin schon hier gelandet gerade
Men of culture sind wieder am start ich sehe schon
Für. Den schrott alles empfohlen
Ja also ich habe mir ich habe mir eine
Fitness uhr gekauft und zwar eine jetzt keine super krass mega teure so eher so eine einsteiger uhr so eine habe ich mir gekauft
Das nehmen wir nicht schäler
So so eine habe ich mir gekauft an sich ich habe ein bisschen dran rum gespielt und so ich habe auch mal getestet wie gut das
mit dem
puls
Messen funktioniert wenn man es nur am handgelenk hat geht erstaunlich gut ich bin ein bisschen die die treppe und runter geflitzt bis bis ich
Irgendwie 145 oder so was habe ich okay hat funktioniert
aber
Es gibt ein problem mit dieser uhr und ich fürchte dass ich die uhr zurückschicken muss weil
Ich weiß nicht was mit dem hersteller los ist meine uhr ist auf firmware 13.23
Es gibt allerdings schon firmware
15.4 oder so was so das passt mal auf garmin forum
Custom firma flashen geht nicht
So ach das eine ist deutsch das eine ist englisch wir könnten wir können auch mal tatsächlich im deutschen forum gucken ob das dann besser
ist so
Es gibt so ein kleines problem
Also erstens dass das garmin forum glaube ich so ziemlich das hässlichste forum aller zeiten ist und das liegt nicht an meinem
Dark reader sondern das liegt daran dass das forum einfach
Eklig ist aber immerhin immerhin kann man das machen was ich bei vielen seiten bemängele man kann durch durch scrollen
Problem ist nur dass man manche post nicht richtig öffnen kann und so was aber es gibt so ein kleines problem
seit
Ungefähr zwei monaten zwei monate leute
Seit zwei monaten kann man die uhr nicht mehr updaten
So jetzt hat garmin offiziell mal was geschrieben
Es macht so viel already know we are aware that a number of x2 x
55 devices are unable to update firmware
Ja, sehr schön
We hope to have a fix soon, but don't have a timeline
Das ist seit zwei monaten seit fucking zwei
Monaten gehen die updates nicht
So und wisst ihr was das problem ist ich hätte ja gar keine schmerzen damit meine woche zu warten bis die firmware es wieder gehen
Das problem ist nur dass die apps auf der uhr nicht aktualisiert werden können und dass du keine neuen apps auf die uhr installieren kannst
Ohne firmware update wenn du nämlich versuchst in den in den
Ja es ist ja nicht wirklich ein store es ist alles kostenlos ja in dem app store
Also wenn du wenn du in diesen garmin garmin in diese garmin app verwaltung reingehst und sagst hier
Ich will hat die auch ein pulsmesser
die apple apple watch se
So wenn du wenn du in den app store gehst
Dann sagt er dir ja um die app um die apps installieren zu können bitte updaten sie die firmware version
Und wenn du die firmware version updaten willst kommt es wurde keine neue firmware version gefunden du musst dir das mal vorstellen die verkaufen diese uhr
Die hälfte der features geht nicht weil sie updates deaktiviert haben und nach über zwei monaten
posten sie heute
Dass sie aware sind dass das ist problem mit dem updates gibt also das ist ja an unfähigkeit echt kaum noch zu überbieten
Ja schön schön e-mails liegen leute alles klar
Hier die leute posten sich hier kaputt
Die kaufen die neue die kaufen die uhr neu und die können sie nicht updaten und keine apps verwenden weil die irgendwie updates einfach nicht
Also das ist wirklich
absolut dämlich
Also ich werde euch sagen was ich machen werde ich warte diese woche als bis bis montag war dich ab ja es ist ja
Es ist ja im prinzip schon schon mittwoch also ich warte bis montag und wenn das montag
Funktioniert mit dem firmware update dann wird die einfach direkt zu amazon zurückgeschickt ich sehe es überhaupt nicht ein ich
Ich kaufe mir noch keine neue uhr die waren so billig war das ding jetzt auch das hat 250 euro oder so gekostet
Und kann dann die hälfte nicht benutzen weil der hersteller seit zwei monaten seine updates aber nicht hinkriegt das ist wirklich peinlich
Das hat mich vor das hat mich verfahren auch übelst aufgeregt ich denke mir die ganze zeit alle warum funktioniert es nicht ich habe mir
Sogar extra es ist ja schon wieder ist ja schon wieder so ein weiteres die guck mal es gibt passt mal auf halt es gibt
Garmin connect
Du bekommst 100 prozent bessere uhr oder weiß ich ob das so 100 100 prozent bessere uhr es kommt drauf an was wir machen werden wahrscheinlich
So also es gibt garmin connect es gibt garmin passt mal auf armin iq garmin iq
gibt es noch
Dann gibt es noch garmin express jetzt nicht dass ihr irgendwie etwa denkt es gebe da ein bisschen zu viele apps oder so was so
Garmin connect brauchst du
Um generell alle sachen von deiner uhr abrufen zu können und
Zu firmware updaten und sonst was aber aus irgendwelchen gründen ist der app store
Für die uhren nicht in garmin connect drin ist schon mal richtig hängen geblieben
Dass du überhaupt zwei verschiedene apps brauchst sondern wenn du firmware update machen willst
Dann sagen sie ja manchmal funktioniert das firmware update über die offizielle app nicht dann ladet diese diese
Verkackte windows software runter und versucht ein update darüber habe ich vorhin installiert
Hab versucht den update über usb zu machen sagt mir hat auch gibt auch keine updates und dann kommt der hit als ich die app beenden wollte
Hatte sich in background gepackt und hat 55 prozent cpu last verursacht
also
Ich weiß nicht wie es was mit den hardware herstellern da immer los ist die schaffen einfach nicht gescheit das software herauszubringen
Keine ahnung wie das wieder mehr so verkacken kann
Auch spur spooky musik hier hast du ja richtig gut
wäre very spooky
Guck mal
Guck mal ich kann meine garmen nicht updaten ja
Ich weiß genau so sieht das bei einem sah das bei mir auch aus ist auf dem aktuellen stand
Ich finde auch die sollten ihre software in russ rewriten dann wäre sie wenigstens blazing die fast ich meine auch wenn sie nicht funktioniert
Wer sie immerhin fast
Und antworten verlangen ja ist klar rosi der garmin supporter sagt dann ach ja schön dass du anrufst
Wir fixen das jetzt direkt für dich die kriegen die kriegen einfach die die gegner standard antwort wie arbeiten mit hochdruck an der lösung des
Problems techniker ist informiert gibt es dann als antwort
Alternativ könnten die die software einfach auf github packen ja das wäre auch nicht verkehrt
Okay, zeig mal her
apple watch
Wie lange ist die die akkulaufzeit von der apple watch
Ich glaube ich glaube apple watch ist da nicht das richtige für mich
Ja, genau die garmin hält halt deutlich länger hat aber halt bei weitem nicht so ein
Hochauflösendes gutes display
Also ich ich will jetzt erst mal das garmin die uhr fixt und wenn nicht schicke ich die zurück an amazon
remote desktop manager
Ich weiß nicht um was es geht aber
not pock
Sonst macht ihr doch selbst eine uhr ja genau beste idee ich brauche meine eigene armbanduhr
Das ist kacke aber es ist es ist zugeben es ist schon hart unfähig oder
Es ist schon sehr unfähig
Klopft der clock champ jepp clock
Seit zwei monaten muss man sich mal vorstellen funktioniert der kram nicht
Display bedienung und sowas hat mich alles fast frei als ich als ich am armgelenk hatte überzeugt fand ich fand ich richtig nice
aber als dann gesehen habe ich kann
Keine apps installieren ist halt kacke weil ich möchte beispielsweise
Beispielsweise
Ich will beispielsweise meine wander app damit verbinden und sowas
Und dazu brauchst du eine neue app und das geht halt gerade nicht
so update
Was wir die neue go version leute
Blazingly fast ne moment go was ist der spruch von go
Also wir wissen dass russ blazingly fast ist aber was ist go
Ist go auch blazingly fast
Blazingly fast simply
Ich glaube go hat nicht so einen komischen spruch
Es hat übrigens gar keinen sinn dass ich gerade betriebssystem update mache
Und reboote wir bauen heute wir bauen heute nicht am frontend weiter das kriege ich heute geistig geistig zusammen
Eine güte
Sagen die das selbst ist es weihnachtsmusik
Das sind die credits wollte gerade sagen
Sagen die auf der go seite
Ja das ist auch so ein ding was wir persönlich an go nicht was ich nicht so schön finde an go ich will nicht sagen
Dass es mir gar nicht gefällt
Go ist schon eine ganz gute sprache im vergleich mit manch anderer
Da ist die vm wieder
Das kriege ich heute nicht hin frontend stells machen wir wahrscheinlich dann morgen oder spätestens am wochenende weiter
Stimmt wo ist er der war in die letzten streams immer am start hier was ist denn snap snap ist ein
kann man das packageformat nennen
Die kombination ist so eine art app store und packageformat von canonical das sind die ubuntu hersteller
überlegt gerade ob man die
canonical oder canonical oder wie spricht man hier aus
und das ist ein
sehr
unbeliebtes format
Niemand mag snap ich glaube nicht mal die ubuntu mitarbeiter selber mögen snap
Ich will weder google watch noch noch google fit oder so was ich wollte eigentlich nur
Meine uhr verwenden wo ich 250 euro für ausgegeben habe aber das ist das ist glaube ich zu viel verlangt im iot
Zeitalter da gibt es das nicht
Dann darfst du geld für die uhr ausgeben und darfst die uhr nicht verwenden für das wenn du das verwenden willst
obwohl weiterhin natürlich
Geworben wird damit mit den mit den features aussprache war mal gucken wie spricht man das aus
canonical
achtung
Okay alles klar wissen wir bescheid
Das stimmt ja wobei das ist ja mehr oder weniger für das gleiche
Snap snap ist halt einfach nur schrott
Ich persönlich bin ja auch kein wirklicher fan von flatpak
Einfach hier package manager und gut ist
Auch gelernter pogu manager nicht umsonst
Also mich würde nicht wundern wenn es das sogar gibt weil es gibt ja auch pnpm
Was einfach nur noch packages wie viele sterne hatten das eigentlich auf github github pnpm
Das ist das ist ein javascript package es hat bestimmt 50.000 javascript packages haben wenn die einigermaßen beliebt sind immer 5 milliarden sterne
Okay 24.000 nur 4 und cringe alter wie kann man nur 24.000 sterne haben
Da bin ich ja mehr guck hier
easy
63.000 sterne
Wir haben neuen bug report
Wobei habe ich nicht gestern definiert dass die software keine bugs hat
der hat es
Einfach nicht richtig benutzt
Direkt klausen
Und fix
Nee
Wenn das wenn das webinterface halbwegs taugt dann baue ich den restraum auf und ich glaube dann ist es
Ich habe ja mittlerweile auch ein bisschen erfahrung damit gesammelt wie man die ganzen fiat sachen weil es ist ja eigentlich
Wie heißen die jetzt?
Es ist ja auch nicht mehr stellantis oder wie heißen die denn jetzt die fiat dudes fiat
Da will ich nicht hin
Ach doch
Stellantis ist es
genau
Schon was vom google browser dm mitbekommen auch fangen jetzt wieder mit dem scheiß an ich dachte das ist
Hat sich erledigt
Okay, ich dachte eigentlich es geht mal wieder um manifest v3
Ach google dreht da doch eh frei wisst ihr das ist der aus diesem grund ist es enorm wichtig dass es weiterhin firefox gibt
Und ich finde es schade dass firefox die letzten jahre irgendwie ein bisschen mitgeschafft hat daran firefox abzuschaffen
Man muss sagen firefox war mal der browser schlechthin
Für alle technik begeisterten für alle hackermans und die es werden wollten allein schon durch das große
Plugin ökosystem aber nachdem es firefox ja die letzten jahre über immer weiter verkackt hat mit ihren plugins
Vor allem dass die alle paar versionen nicht mehr gehen und bei bei einem
Großen major update ging ja auch quasi auf einschlag fast keine addons mehr weiß ich nicht ich bin übrigens der meinung also
beziehungsweise aktuell würde ich sagen
Es ist es ist es vielleicht gleichstand aber ich war ja lange jahre der meinung die browser
devtools im firefox
Waren meilenweit besser als das was chrome hatte aber mittlerweile weiß ich weiß ich nicht ob ich das noch sagen würde
Aber gerade aus dem grund pocket und also ich also pocket mag ich tatsächlich
Das habe ich auf dem iphone auch als app um da sachen zu bookmarken
Ja, ja ich im prinzip auch aktuell ich muss sagen ich habe firefox selten benutzt in letzter zeit deswegen bin ich mir gerade ein
bisschen unschlüssig und wollte es nicht ausweihen es ist immer noch so aber wenn du das sagst
Ja, so und deswegen genau wegen diesem scheiß was google treibt ist es wichtig dass firefox gibt dumm ist halt nur
ehrlich das warum
Diese komische diese komische bedienung hier die die im prinzip irgendwie an tablets erinnert geht mir halt auch schon ein bisschen auf den keks
also firefox hätte durchaus
Mehr für ihre
Kernnutzer schafft auf dem desktop tun könnten die letzten
Jahre über alle was mit der musik los es eskaliert ja voll gerade
Aber insgesamt ist wichtig dass wir firefox weiterhin haben dass uns firefox erhalten bleibt
Ich glaube das menü kannst du nicht mehr über die haben ja vor einer ganzen weile ich glaube zu firefox 38 war das haben die
Ganz ganz viele alten alten plugin apis rausgeschmissen das war auch der zeitpunkt wo das alte no script nicht mehr ging
Kennt ihr noch kennt ihr noch das alte no script wo du wirklich jeden scheiß einzeln ploggen und einstellen konntest
Da ist das neue no script und you blog origin nix dagegen das alte no script war extrem
Lieb hogu zufrieden sein als nicht dass es nicht noch besser geht
Ich finde die müssten sich auch ein bisschen mehr von chrome
Abheben und das machst du eben am besten damit indem du weißt was deine hauptzielgruppe ist und ich glaube das firefox
Zielgruppe ist nicht die oma auf dem tablet sondern der technik interessierte benutzer auf dem desktop
Eventuell unter android okay
Ich glaube das nimmt sich alles nicht
Da sind sich alles nicht viel also letztens hat apple erzählt
Unser browser ist der schnellste browser im javascript benchmark gut dass safari
So schnell ist habe ich gesagt der schlauste browser ich wollte sagen der schnellste browser falls der schlauste browser
Ist der schnellste browser im javascript benchmark bei safari wundert mich das aber auch nicht
safari kann ja die hälfte von modernen webstandards nicht insofern muss man sich nicht
Wundern dass safari schneller ist und ansonsten geben sich so die letzten jahre über firefox und chrome ein bisschen so
Die klinke in die hand was den schnellsten browser angeht wobei
Ich würde print tendenziell sagen google hat meistens die nase vorne
Kann man safari eigentlich von mac os deleten
Keine ahnung habe ich noch nie ausprobiert ich habe kein mac os
Ich könnte mir vorstellen das geht nicht richtig du kannst vielleicht die app entfernen dann wird sie nicht mehr angezeigt du kannst
Du nicht mal starten aber viele interne sachen basieren wahrscheinlich weiterhin auf safari
Das ist das ist ein bisschen so wie chrome von android an installen oder oder ja das
Der interne web der webview wird trotzdem intern noch total oft benutzt
Es gibt ein paar alternativen zu elektronen immer mehr aber die haben halt nicht die nötige die nötige verbreitung
Es gibt dieses ding was auf rust basiert was immer die jeweils native browser engine nimmt es gibt webview 2
Das ist das das ist quasi edge
hv 8
Embedded in einem eigenen fenster
Ja
Und es gibt ein paar andere javascript engines aber du hast schon recht so eine richtige richtige alternative zu v8 gibt es eigentlich nicht
Sie können einfach firefox über ein paket manager anbieten und gut ist ja tauri gibt es auch noch ich glaube tauri ist das war
Github
Das ist das was den jeweils native webview verwendet
blazingly fast
Ritten in rust ist es überhaupt in rust
natürlich was sonst
rost
Wollte eigentlich
Geht's mal weg
Weil ich hier was suchen rust aber das verwendet unter der haube glaube ich den native webview
Das ist doch irgendwie so so komisch gemacht und wenn nicht fallback zu v8
zu zu zu
Wie heißt blink nee wie heißt die web engine von
Von chrome
Blink kann das sein
Die die render engine ja noch blink
Genau guck die verwenden entweder
webkit
Was auch hoch fragwürdig ist weil diese dinger meistens total outdated sind von den libraries her
Und massig sicherheitsprobleme haben
Sie ein das ist ja eines der gründe warum
Android und ios und auch viele linux distributionen den browser mittlerweile aus ihrem normalen aus ihrem normalen update
Zyklus rausgezogen haben so dass du dir dass sie den quasi ja patchen können ohne
Da sich viel gedanken machen zu müssen und der android war ja bis zu android 6 oder so
War ja der webview und der browser
Es war irgendwie aneinander
Gebundelt im betriebssystem also du konntest den den betriebssystem webview nicht einfach austauschen
Mittlerweile das haben sie ja auch schon erkannt dass es deutlich sinnvoller ist wenn das geht
Aber vor acht für javascript wird es immer noch unter der haube sein weil was willst du sonst machen
Für javascript bleibt dir außer vor acht nicht wirklich was übrig
Gibt zwar ein paar andere javascript engines aber so wirklich nennenswert
gut gut integriert für desktop
Glaubt fällt mir jetzt nichts anderes ein als vor acht und letztendlich note ja
Oder meinetwegen auch denno aber ich weiß nicht ob es ob es elektron mit denno gibt anstatt note gibt es sowas
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Edge ist chrome ja mittlerweile ist das noch chrome
Denno ist auch vor acht ja ja ich weiß ich sag ja es kann auch denno sein das ist alles vor acht
Weiß ich was was verwendet ban denn unter der haube bestimmt auch vor acht oder
Oder was verwenden die unter der haube
Ach nee die benutzen webkit ok
Ich bring es immer durcheinander
Webkit
Warte mal warte mal
Webkit ist das ursprüngliche worauf safari und chrome basiert basierten
In
Oder
Und chrome hat es irgendwann gefolgt und blinkt raus gemacht und safari verwendet es immer noch
Krieg ich das richtig bringt das richtig zusammen
Firefox hat ja was eigenes
Mein auge
Firefox hat was eigenes chrome
Genau bis april 2013 war google an der weiterentwicklung seitdem haben die das gefolgt
Und jetzt gibt es safari basiert eigentlich noch drauf ja genau
Das heißt ban verwendet webkit
Firefox ist vor acht die hatten doch lange eine eigene javascript irgendwas irgendwas mit monkey oder sowas
lesen das
spider monkey
Die gecko ist der html render zeug
Nee still usable firefox
Das haben die ausgetauscht wirklich
Ach ja wirklich
das nicht sagen oder
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert das hätte ich wahrscheinlich hätte ich mitgekriegt
Das haben die nicht ausgetauscht die haben in einen krempel
Na ja mir fällt gerade ein wir wollten uns doch das video vom aua angucken
Worauf eins und eins war kommt das war mir jetzt das gucken wir uns jetzt an
Und immer gespannter 25 video erkennt mich mit 25 minuten video brauche ich wahrscheinlich eben eine stunde bis dadurch
Zeit war ja der bauer
Zeigt uns heute das rechenzentrum glaube ich mal oder von 1 und 1
Hallo zusammen herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren video wie ihr sehen könnt wir sind nicht bei mir zu hause im studio sondern wir stehen hier
Zwischen zwei großen diesel generatoren denn wir machen mal wieder eine rechenzentrums tour und wir sind heute bei ionos
Denn wir haben auch ein rechenzentrum in berlin das ist für mich sehr praktisch dann das war relativ nah
Von da wo ich wohne und das interessante daran ist dass ich auch schon seit über
15 jahren kunde bei ionos bin damals noch eins und eins ja und ich ich auch ich habe einen euro server
Also kann man sagen ich bin auch kunde bei denen aber ich bin sicherlich keiner der viel geld dort lässt
Ein euro im monat kostet der server immer noch den habt das haben die auch nie erhöht
deswegen auch für mich ein euro im monat v server
Das ding funzt das ist aber einfach da und geht
Interessant einfach mal zu sehen was machen die eigentlich wie sieht es da alles aus wir machen heute so eine kleine tour durch das
Rechenzentrum wir fangen ganz am anfang bei der infrastruktur an deswegen stehen wir hier auch gerade vor den
Dieselgeneratoren die hoffentlich nie laufen müssen denn die laufen ja nur wenn irgendwie mal gehört so wie laut so ein dieselgenerator ist leute
Weiß ich weiß ich auch wieder mal in der nähe wart wenn so einen notstrom aggregats diesel
Generator anläuft alter ich sage euch
Da haut sie die ohren weg
Also ich kenne das ja
Gut ich kann ich weiß nicht ob es wie ein schiffsmotor ist ich weiß nicht ob das
Schiff aber es ist laut ich habe das mitbekommen und auch nur durch eine tür und mit ohrschutz auf
Habe ich das mitbekommen mal bei einem ausfall test bei uns im keller bei einem standort
rechenzentrums strom strom ausfall test
Du spürst das auch richtig ja dass das ding hochdreht es ist nicht es ist nicht so dass du das nur
Brummen hörst und
Das ist das drei komponenten einmal es ist laut das fack
Es brummt das hörst du trotz gehörschutz und allem und du merkst das auch wenn du in der nähe bist dass das hochdreht also
Okay wärme konnte ich jetzt so nicht beurteilen ich war ja ich war ja nicht direkt im gleichen raum
Wahrscheinlich durften wir auch gar nicht im gleichen raum sein also ich sage euch das ist wirklich ordentlich das ist das echt laut
Das ist wirklich laut und es vibriert auch also die dinger die hauen rein
Strom weg ist was in berlin die haben aber mehr als wir
Also bei bei bei der alten firma wo ich war also das sieht das sieht mehr aus hier
unser unser diesel
Notstrom heißt das aggregat
Die in diesen lotto das war
Vielleicht so die hälfte hiervon und im einen die haben ja hier irgendwer irgendwie
Mindestens zwei wahrscheinlich dass es auch ausfall sicher ist falls eins davon abkackt
Aber es ist laut auch das kleine war schon laut will ich wissen was die dinger ja wenn die wenn die hochdrehen
Und jetzt kann ich euch noch was erzählen
Das war es war eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich clever gemacht das ausfallkonzept im letzten
Kellerrechenzentrum von meinem letzten arbeitgeber das war kombiniert das war nicht nur so ein diesel notstrom
Aggregat das hatte auch noch
Ein also wie gesagt das übelst laut gewesen das hatte auch noch einen
Ja ich weiß nicht wie man das nennt das ist so ein ding was sich dreht die ganze zeit
Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen
Ihr habt ein gewicht mit ein paar hundert kilo
Keine turbine nein nein nein keine keine turbine
Schwungrad sowas in der richtung ja also ihr habt ja irgendwie ein gewicht mit ein paar hundert kilo
das dreht sich
Und also die ganze zeit wird das aber wird das angetrieben das hat natürlich das das kostet natürlich auch sinnlos energie aber gut
So ihr habt ihr habt ein paar hundert kilo gewicht das dreht sich die ganze zeit im kreis und wenn der strom ausfällt
Dann dreht sich das gewicht
noch weiter
Ist ja klar ja wenn du ein paar hundert kilo gewicht hast was ich was ich schon was ich schnell im kreis dreht da hat es
Ja einen gewissen schwung drauf an gewissen energie
und
Wenn der strom dann ausfällt dann dreht sich das gewicht noch ein paar mal weiter und dann hast du für zwei drei sekunden
noch strom und das ist die zeit die du brauchst um zu überbrücken bis der diesel anspringt
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich clever gemacht
Du hast quasi ein nahezu ausfall sich ein nicht ausfall
Also du hast quasi eine sache die im prinzip nicht ausfallen kann ja außer dir bricht das gewicht durch oder so
Und
Keine batterien doch ich gehe davon aus dass die auch batterien haben hatten irgendwie zusätzlich fragt mich nicht
Aber das war einmal also ich weiß dass dies das ausfall konzept darauf basierte du hast ein diesel und du hast die möglichkeiten
mit diesem
mit diesem gewicht was darum saust
Irgendwie paar sekunden zu überbrücken besser diesel anspringt
Es kann durchaus auch sein
Das noch zwischendurch auf batterien umgeschaltet als fragt mir nicht genau ich hatte mit dem rechten zentrum letzten gebäude nicht allzu viel zu
Tun so rein von der infrastruktur her das war schon ganz interessant und diesel eine sache die hier hat man wie sie gemerkt hat das
Ding ist abfahrt laut wenn das hochdreht das brummt und das vibriert
Also hast du echt das gefühl also das ist nicht so das kommt dir nicht vor wie irgendwie lkw oder so das kommt dir schon ungefähr
so vor
Wie ja es ist ein bisschen man kann es ein bisschen beschreiben
Kennt ihr motorradfahrer die
Weiß ich in auspuff manipuliert haben oder sowas die die das motorräder wenn die schnell fahren und dass die mega laut sind
So wenn ihr da daneben steht ungefähr so kann man sich das kann man sich das vorstellen
und
dass das wenn ihr nachts
Wenn ihr nachts das fenster offen habt an der straße wohnt da fährt so ein typ vorbei mit so einem motorrad ungefähr so kann man
sich das gefühl vorstellen so ungefähr in dieser richtung nur noch ein bisschen
Mächtiger kann ich das vorstellen wenn so diesel teil anläuft und ihr steht schon nicht direkt daneben
Ihr steht schon in einem in einem raum daneben wo eine wand dazwischen ist
Okay weiter jetzt möglicherweise selten der fall ist in dem rechenzentrum wo wir heute sind befinden sich circa 25.000 server
Jonas hat insgesamt ungefähr 100.000 dachte ich die heißen jonas aber ich glaube er hat recht
Bei der aussprache thematik fällt mir immer wieder ein dass ja auch alle asus falsch aussprechen
Und dass asus keine probleme mit der aussprache asus hat auch wenn es offiziell eigentlich asus ist
Aber was asus gar nicht mag habe ich mir sagen lassen ist aces
Hat mir hat mir mal so ein paar leute von asus erzählt
Ja, asus ist eigentlich nicht ganz korrekt aber asus ist kein problem aber aces mögen sie nicht weil manche amis für den asus wohl
aces aussprechen
Asus
Schon eine sehr sehr große anzahl und ich bin gespannt was wir da heute sehen können bei den generatoren hier ist es so
Links und rechts von mir natürlich große diesel sowas was man auch in dem schiff haben könnte im etwas größeren kahn
Und die haben circa 3000 ps pro teil also auch circa 3000 kv a leistung falls
Es mal ein problem mit der stromversorgung gibt die stromversorgung normalerweise würden wir jetzt dabei
Bei der trafo station vielleicht starten wo eben die
Energie von außen im rechenzentrum zugeführt wird da können wir nicht rein aus guten gründen weil ja sind 10.000 volt wir wollen ja auch
Noch länger leben deswegen gehen wir da nicht rein und starten hierbei der
Ja
Da also wenn ich vor einer sache schiss habt dann ist es wirklich strom also hochspannung und irgendwelche elektroinstallation
Wo ich nicht genau weiß wie weit man wohin wie rangehen darf da habe ich schiss vor
Und jetzt gehen wir mal weiter wir machen erst mal weiter mit der infrastruktur wir sind hier in der niederspannungs hauptverteilung
Und generell erstmal vom aufbau her ist auch hier in dem rechenzentrum alles redundant angelegt das sieht man erst mal daran dass die
Von euch aus gesehen rechte seite die ist blau markiert und die von euch aus gesehen linke seite die ist orange markiert
Und das ist rechenzentrum typisch dass man versucht alles in doppelter ausführung dazu haben
Habt ihr gesehen was da hinten steht man sieht es gar nicht ach nee ist es nicht ich dachte so ein guter alter
Wagen die dinger die man nicht richtig steuern kann aber wo gerne aus irgendwelchen gründen immer technik mit rum gefahren wird
Wissen wisst ihr was ich meine diese diese wegen die man nicht richtig steuern kann die es aber überall gibt
Blau markiert und die von euch aus gesehen linke seite die ist orange markiert und das ist die die die nur
Quasi gezogen und gesteuert werden können aber nicht geschoben und gesteuert werden können
Ja genau nur vorne drehbare räder dass das das meine ich richtig
Fisch dass man versucht alles in doppelter ausführung dazu haben das war schon bei den generatoren so da haben wir auch nur ein raum gezeigt
Es gibt es auch doppelt weil es kann ja immer sein dass irgendwas ausfällt
Und für den schlimmsten fall will man ja alles doppelt haben damit einfach alles immer laufen kann
Grundsätzlich ist es hier so dass ja die spannung von außen mit 10.000 volt ankommt es geht durch den transformator und kommt dann hier
Mit 400 volt in diesem raum an und dann hat man eben diese ganzen verteilerkästen was am ende nichts anderes ist als bei euch zuhause
Im haus nur dass das alles ein bisschen größer ist also zuhause hat man eine 16 ampere sicherung hier ist es halt
1600 ampere also ein kleines bisschen größer
Ansonsten ist das alles das gleiche und das was man hier sehen kann sind dann die einzelnen kästen wo die stromschienen oben rausgehen die
Dann zu den einzelnen elektrischen anlagen und das kann hier seht ihr das kommt vom generator dann
Mit dem part kenne ich mich rechenzentrums technisch nicht aus mit elektro elektro
versorgung und sowas keine ahnung
3.3 steht 2.3
Das sind dann die einzelnen elemente die zu den rechenzentren hochgehen also das ist im prinzip die
Stromversorgung die damit 400 volt über stromschienen also deswegen sieht es auch so aus das sind keine kabel
Riesenfetten kupferplatten die dann gebogen werden bis oben hin
Elektronik kurs unter euch
aus einer normalen steckdose
darfst du ja nur
Maximal wie er hat ja auch gesagt gibt es nur maximal 16 ampere 230 volt 16 ampere
Und im dauerbetrieb darfst du glaube ich oder solltest du aus den meisten steckdosen sogar nur maximal 10 ampere
aber
Was habe ich denn für eine sicherung bei meinem bei meiner auto
bei einem autoladegerät
Die die bei der ladestation
Die da muss ich habe ich extra elektriker geholt dass er 22 11
11 kilowatt ladegerät glaube und das muss speziell angeschlossen werden
Das ist das sind das sind dann 400 volt 16 ampere
glaube ich oder oder sind es
32 32 wären es bei 22 kilowatt ladestationen
glaube 16
Genau irgendwie irgendwie sowas genau also okay es ist weiter eine 16 ampere sicherung
Drei mal ja ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert aber das klingt das klingt korrekt
an die rechenzentren
Was auch noch ganz kurz erwähnt sei auch hier in dem rechenzentrum ist natürlich für die sicherheit immer gesorgt das heißt hier hinten hinter mir
Ja ich habe aber nicht 22 habe 11
Mit 22 muss das der ersten antrag bei den stadtwerken stellen und sowas hatte ich kein bock drauf gibt es wieder so eine rauchansauganlage
das heißt
Bei diesen anlagen die man hier sehen kann also werdet ihr wahrscheinlich in anderen räumen und auch sehen können da gibt es immer
Diese diese kästen mit den rohren dran
Und die sage ich mal sind schlaue interaktive rauchmelder das heißt die saugen die ganze zeit luft an
Und messen die partikel die in der luft drin sind weil bei den normalen haushaltsrauch quasi ein high-IQ
Rauchmelder so dass er in der regel nur auslöst über
viele
Partikel die in der luft sind das heißt wenn da mal rauch ist dann wird irgendwie licht blockiert und dann weiß der jo hier brennt es
Vielleicht und bei so einer anlage da misst man halt schon vorher kleinste mengen an partikeln und weiß dann okay
Hier könnte es ein problem sein ohne dass man hier wirklich rauch sehen würde also es wird dann eben wesentlich früher erkannt
Als es beim rauchmelder zu hause der fall wäre wenn es doch mal brennen sollte was hoffentlich nie passiert
Dann seht ihr hier oben eine leitung die läuft ja nach schatten ich war einmal im rechten zentrum hohes feueralarm gegeben hat
Nicht bei uns also nicht bei uns am standort sondern wo wir uns eingemietet haben damals in frankfurt gab es feueralarm
Es war aber kein feuer es gab nur feueralarm ich weiß nicht wo der feuer
Das du also es gibt ja einmal so co location sachen da kriegst du halt so ein rack kannst dann das heuch reinstellen wir hatten halt ein
Komplett eigenes abteil gemietet so und da waren wir da und auf einmal gab es feueralarm da mussten wir alle ganz schnell raus
Und wir durften irgendwie erst eineinhalb stunden später oder so wieder rein
Und ne ich glaube also da bin da bin ich mir nicht sicher ob die ob die irgendwas mit
Mit was wir mit was machen die das immer zum flammen ersticken keine ahnung ob die da irgendwas hatten für
Was machen die denn da
Keine ahnung weil sie nicht es ging weder es ging es ging weder
irgendwelche
Sprinkler an noch gingen irgendwelche anderen sachen bei uns alles bei uns würde nichts hardware mäßig beschädigt aber feueralarm mussten alle raus
Und wir durften glaube ich erst eineinhalb stunden später wieder rein
Und was haben wir gemacht das schon ewig her da habe ich da war ich noch in der ausbildung schon ganz lange her
Und was haben wir gemacht wir haben uns einfach eine stunde bei mcdonald's hingesetzt und haben gefressen
Als arbeitszeit weil
Wir wollten ja arbeiten konnten aber nicht steht auch an der seite stichstoff drauf
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie eine dusche möchte ich nicht hier in dem raum sein aber dann wird der raum mit stichstoff geflutet werden
Und das verdrängt natürlich allen sauerstoff führt dazu dass wenn ein brand irgendwo vielleicht
Entstehen ist dass der sich aber ich bin mir relativ sicher dass die dort
Also zumindest in unserem abteil wo unser rechtsrecht zentrum war da war nix mit stichstoff da durfte man danach auch ohne
Probleme wieder rein die haben uns nach eineinhalb stunden einfach wieder reingelassen und da ist auch nix irgendwie von der decke
Irgendwas gewesen ich weiß auch unsere server hatten keinerlei probleme war alles okay
Nix nass nix eingeschäumt nicht sonst was also ich glaube die haben es schon gecheckt dass es ein falscher alarm war falsche alarm war
Gar nicht erst ausbreiten kann oder dann den fall eben komplett gelöscht wird einmal im jahr wird dann auch der so genannte black building test
Gemacht das heißt da wird dann einfach getestet ob die generatoren und alles was man an infrastruktur hat auch im
Wirklich reellen einsatz funktioniert das heißt über so eine steuerung hier kann man das dann so
Koordinieren dass man das rechenzentrum im prinzip von der außenwelt trennt also die externe stromversorgung
Und dann nur mit der internen stromversorgung arbeitet weil man muss natürlich auch sicherstellen dass das was man als stehen hat auch immer
Funktioniert die generatoren werden auch einmal im monat getestet
Aber das ist dann nicht dieser vollständige black building test wo man dann das rechenzentrum auch tatsächlich mit dem strom der generatoren versorgt
Ja wir sind jetzt ein paar etagen höher und auch ein paar etagen lauter wie ihr wahrscheinlich hören könnt weil sie so ein
Fiepen wahrnehmen können das liegt daran weil wir neben der usv stehen und das brechensprei
Ja das ist ein zungenbrecher das passiert mir auch öfters
Deswegen bevorzuge ich tatsächlich mittlerweile an interoperable power supply, aber
unterbrechungsfreie stromversorgung ist auch echt heftiges wort
Hier kommt die stromversorgung von unten an
Wieder eben mit den 400 volt und das ganze geht ja durch die usv durch also usv ist am ende nichts anderes
Chetkis
Welcher fachinformatiker hat aufgepasst für seine abschlussprüfung
Welche sorte von usv ist das
Oder ups wenn wir es auf englisch sagen wollen
Ja hört es euch mal an
Hier kommt die stromversorgung von unten an
Wieder eben mit den 400 volt
Und das ganze geht ja durch die usv durch
Also usv ist am ende nichts anderes
Es geht durch die usv
Es ist also auf jeden fall eine online usv
Ich weiß nicht was für eine subkategorie
Das wisst ihr eher als ich
Bei euch ist es noch nicht so lange her
Bevor ihr die abschlussprüfung geschrieben habt
Aber das müsste eine online usv sein
Wenn ich das richtig zusammenkriege
Nicht Line Interactive
Line Interactive ist doch die geschichte die umschaltet wenn der strom weg ist
Soll man sagen
Eine große batterie die dafür sorgt
Dass im schlimmsten fall
Wenn der strom von außen gekappt wird
Dass hier nicht direkt das licht aus ist
Sondern das sind halt batterien
Und die batterien können bis zu 20 minuten volllast
Circa
Dieses ganze rechenzentrum hier versorgen
Weil natürlich wenn der strom von außen
Im alten rechenzentrum auch
Viertelstunde 20 minuten
Dann dauert es auch ganz kurz bis die generatoren anlaufen
Es dauert vielleicht 1-2 minuten
Aber diese 1-2 minuten
Bis die generatoren den strom liefern
Für das rechenzentrum
Müssen natürlich überprüft werden
Und das macht dann die usv die neben mir steht
Auch hier
Vielleicht habe ich euch im vorfeld auch Mist erzählt
Vielleicht gab es echt noch zusätzlich batterien
Dort wo ich euch erzählt habe
Von dem test wo ich dabei gewesen bin
Aber ich habe auf jeden fall nur das mit dem gewicht
Und den generatoren mitgekriegt
Vielleicht waren da zur überprüfung
Dort auch batterien keine ahnung
Mit den unterschiedlichen farben
Das sieht man auch hier wieder
Da kommt einmal orange hoch und einmal blau hoch
Wir sind jetzt eigentlich auf der blauen seite
Die orange seite gibt es nochmal drüben
Und die usvs die wir jetzt hier neben mir stehen
Äh sehen
Sieht man auch das gehören zur blauen seite
Und jede von den seiten
Ist da die ausfallsicherheit
Das bedeutet
Dass die blaue seite natürlich
Den kompletten teil hier versorgen kann
Und auch die usvs die hier stehen
Können den kompletten blauen teil versorgen
Und das doppelt
Also auch die usvs
Sagt man n plus 1
Sind die ausgelegt dass sie das ganze versorgen können
Und jetzt komme ich im prinzip gerade
Von dem orangen entgang hinter mir
Und laufen wir zwischen diesen ganzen batterien durch
Boah
Das ist ordentlich
Zu verfügung stellen können
Also soviel batterien
Hatten wir im rechenzentrum nicht
Auch im alten nicht
Und auch in den anderen
Rechenzentren
Damals wo ich noch beim provider gearbeitet habe
In dem
In der größe nicht
Mal soweit sein
Seht ihr hier drin
Und die sind auch deswegen hier so eingekapselt
Also sieht man durch diese
Wahrscheinlich Acryl oder sowas
Da sind die batterien drin
Und die batterien wenn ich hier hin fasse
Da kommt ein bisschen mehr kalte luft entgegen
Beziehungsweise ich merke dass das teil hier kalt ist
Weil die batterien werden auch gekühlt
Ja ok
In den meisten rechenzentren ist es auch hier so
Wir stehen ja hier auf einem boden
Aber es ist nicht wie zu hause
Ja gut das ist ja normal
Hier hat man eben dieses typische
Konzept mit den kalt und warmen
Gängen das bedeutet unter mir
Findet sich überall kalte luft
Und wenn man so eine platte hier raus nimmt
Dann kommt mehr kalte luft entgegen
Hat nicht letztens von euch mal im chat jemand erzählt
Dass er als Azubi unten
Unter den bodenplatten immer gepennt hat
Ohne erwischt zu werden
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe was mit euch los
Das gleiche hat man im prinzip da wo die
Batterien stehen das heißt da ist unten offen
Da kann kalte luft zu den batterien strömen
Und dann werden die gekühlt
Man versucht ja immer ca. 20°C
Zu halten bei den batterien
Weil dann halten die einfach deutlich länger
Die hier im sommer zum Beispiel bei 35 oder 40°C
Stehen würden
So eine platte haben wir jetzt aus dem boden mal rausgenommen
Und da sieht man hier unter mir laufen zwei so
Gräulich laufende schienen lang
Und das sind die schienen auf denen
Dann der Strom letztendlich zu den
Servern geführt wird das sind schienen die
Jeweils 160A führen
Und dann sind diese kleinen Kästen hier dran
Wo man einfach an einen kleinen Sicherungskasten
Denken kann
Ok genug Stromversorgung ich brauche Server
Ja Netzwerk ach komm wir lassen jetzt laufen
Der Kasten der ist mit 63A abgesichert
Geht es dann neben mir zu den Racks
Und auch hier ist es natürlich wieder so
Dass wir die Stromversorgung ja doppelt haben
An den Server ran das heißt zwei Stromschienen
Gehen logischerweise an einen von diesen Schränken
Und dann ist es hier auch farblich gekühlt
Ok sieht man schon im Vergleich zu Hetzner
Scheint das ganz normale 19 Zoll Server
Hardware zumindest an der Stelle
Ganz normale 19 Zoll Server Hardware zu sein
Wir sehen es jetzt nicht so ganz aber
Sieht erstmal so aus
Kennzeichnet da haben wir dann auch
Weiße und schwarze Kabel
Die jeweils an einen Server gehen
Das sieht man auch hinten wenn man hier mal so hinschaut
Da sieht man das sind zwei Netzteile drin
Und da haben wir einmal ein weißes
Hier seht ihr übrigens eine Sache die im Rechenzentrum
Heutzutage auch immer noch allgegenwärtig ist
Ein VGA Ausgang
Selbst die neuesten
Kisten
Wobei die sind nicht so
Ach guck mal HP
Von der Farbe her würde ich sagen
Das ist HP oder was meint ihr
Von diesem
Mein Dell hat auch so
Ein bisschen gräulich
Aber ich würde sagen das ist HP
Von der Farbe her
Sieht so nach einer typischen
HP Blende aus
Und jetzt auch nicht unbedingt nach dem
Aller frischsten
Aber VGA haben die trotzdem alle noch
Super Micro
Das kann auch sein die haben auch ähnliche Farben
Aber
Für mich ist das so die typische
HP Farbe
So ein alter Dell 380
Stimmt ja ach die haben den Kram umbenannt
Ne guck mal hier
Immer noch die typische
HP Farbe ist dran
Ich kenn auch die alten
Guck so die typische
HP Farbe
Die man hier sieht
Ich geh davon aus
Es könnte auch Super Micro sein
Aber
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal pauschal
Sagen HP
HP Hardware ist auch deutlich verbreiteter
Im Rechenzentrum als Super Micro
Also insofern ich sag einfach mal HP
Ein HP Server
Genau
Die Netzteile auch redundant sind
Aber dementsprechend auch die Stromversorgung
Und so ist es farblich gekennzeichnet
Dass die auch immer wissen
Welche Seite ist denn was
Was A oder Schwarz B ist
Aber auf jeden Fall hat man dann immer
Das eine oder das andere
Ja das war bei uns auch so
Wenn man hier Service macht
Immer weiß
Also das war überall
In jedem Rechenzentrum so
Dass du bei den Schienen unterschiedliche Stromversorgung hattest
Und du hast ja bei den Servern
Meistens auch zwei verschiedene Netzteile
Das ist recht
Standard sag ich mal
Guck mal hier schon mal ein paar Glasfaserkabel durch
Stromversorgung dran
Womit die Auswahlsicherheit immer gegeben ist
Was man vielleicht gerade auf der Aufnahme nicht gesehen hat
Was ich aber sehr interessant finde
Ich hatte mich kurz gewundert
Was hier oben denn eigentlich
Schön ordentlich
Muss man sagen
Das sah
Nicht überall so schön aus
Wieder hier
Also
Das Rechenzentrum wo ich am meisten
Gewesen bin
Was ist
Ist sie gehört
Wow
Hat sie gemacht gerade
Was ist
Jetzt geht sie wieder weg
Okay
Ja also in dem Rechenzentrum
Wo ich am meisten gewesen bin bei uns in Frankfurt
Das ist übrigens das Rechenzentrum
Wo ich euch erzählt habe, dass es nicht im Keller gebaut werden konnte
Sondern im sechsten Stock
Oder im fünften Stock irgendwo
Weil der Vorstand
Seinen Parkplatz nicht aufgeben wollte
Ihr seht im Business Enterprise Umfeld
Ist auch nicht unbedingt alles immer rein von
Logik geprägt
Und zumindest dort
Sah das bei weitem nicht so
Ordentlich aus wie hier
Da gab es Netzwerkkabelschränke
Da gingen die Türen nicht mal mehr zu
Und keiner hat sich getraut die Tür quasi
Zuzudrücken, weil er Angst hatte er reißt
Irgendwelche Kabel da raus oder knickt sie
Ab
Dieser gelbe Kanal der hier überall rumläuft
Weil natürlich die Stromversorgung ist unten
Auf den ersten Blick denkt man das ist irgendwie Strom
Oder sowas, aber
Das gelbe, da liegt überall
Glasfaser drin
Die ganzen Sachen sind natürlich, wenn es schnell gehen muss
Logischerweise über Glasfaser verbunden
Vor allem weil es ja
Fieberoptik
Also typische Netzwerkkabel
Aber wie man sehen kann, hier sind auch über Netzwerkkabel dran
Und damit sich das Ganze
Ja gut, die Glasfaser könnten ja auch hauptsächlich für Storage
Sein, je nachdem wie die das machen
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es für normalen
Netzwerktraffic und Storage
Lichtwellenleiter
Korrekt
Nicht hier mit irgendwelchen komischen Anglizismen
Lichtwellenleiter
Weil Netzwerkkabel
Kann man einfacher irgendwie
Handeln, irgendwie reinlegen als Glasfaser
Deswegen liegen Glasfaserkabel
Immer in den gelben Kanälen drin
Dass die mechanisch nicht
Durch Netzwerkkabel irgendwie belastet werden
Oder beeinträchtigt werden, weil
So ordentlich sind wir nicht gewesen
Das aber klingt mir nach einer sehr sinnvollen Idee
Wäre, dann könnten da auch
Beschädigungen entstehen und das vermeidet man so
Jetzt befinden wir uns in einem der
Kaltgänge, wo letztendlich auch Server stehen
Die hört man hinter mir nämlich ziemlich laut
Schreien
Ich wollte gerade mal was zum Thema Glasfaserkabel
Erzählen
Bei meiner aller aller
Also noch wo ich noch
War ich noch Azubi damals
Bei meiner aller aller ersten Wartung
In einem Rechenzentrum
Da waren wir fertig
Wir haben Firewall-Firmware-Upgrades gemacht
Weiß ich heute noch
Sind wir nochmal durchgelaufen und ich hab die Jacke schon angezogen
Und dann bin ich mit meiner Jacke
Hängen geblieben vorne an einem Glasfaserkabel
An einem Switch
Und hab das Glasfaserkabel
Rausgerissen
Mitsamt dem Glasfasermodul
Und ich hab's einfach
Ganz schnell wieder reingesteckt
Bin weitergelaufen und hab gehofft, dass nichts passiert
Und anscheinend ist auch nichts passiert
Aber dann hab ich mir echt ein bisschen die Hose geschissen
Hat auch nie jemand was gesagt
Wieso nachts?
Geht das nicht in einem HA in Weyermann
Im laufenden Betrieb
Auch wenn du HA-mäßig
Deine Sachen aufgebaut hast
Es gibt immer Hardware
Die schwierig ist parallel zu upgraden
Und damals
War das mit HA
Mit der Netzwerk-Firewall-Infrastruktur
Nicht so weit her
Da sind Unternehmen generell
Nicht so risikoaffin
Die sagen, mach das lieber trotzdem nachts
Auch wenn nichts passieren sollte
Streng genommen finde ich das
Verständlich, aber
Nicht sinnvoll, weil
Gerade wenn du
Ein Netzwerk, lass ich mir vielleicht noch gefallen
Aber gerade wenn du Services updatest
Irgendwelche Versionen oder irgendwelche neue
Infrastruktursachen austauscht
VMs
Runterfährst, eine Update wieder hochfährst
Es ist meistens besser, man macht das zu normalen Zeiten
Wenn die Leute da sind
Die sich mit den Problemen auskennen und das besser fixen können
Wenn was in die Hose geht
Also
Ich persönlich bin ein Fan von
Wartungsarbeiten
Auch kritische Wartungsarbeiten
Wenn es die Infrastruktur hergibt
Auch ganz normal am Tag zu machen
Aber Netzwerk
Ist immer so ein Spezialding
Die Internet-Anbindung
Nach draußen von dem Rechenzentrum
Da haben wir 4x100 Gigabit
Beziehungsweise hier
2x100 Gigabit
Und dann in dem Gang neben uns
Ich glaube einen Raum weiter
Nochmal 2x100 Gigabit Anbindung
Das ist ordentlich
Da geht die Steam-Downloads
Auf jeden Fall ordentlich zügig
Von diesen einzelnen Einheiten wird es dann natürlich weiter verteilt
Also hier neben mir sind ganz viele
Verteilt
Steam könnte ja so viel gar nicht liefern auf einmal
Aber das ist natürlich ordentlich
Ich bilde mir ein
Wir hatten damals
Nur
2 Gigabit Synchron
An dem einen Standort
Also doppelt
2x2 Gigabit
Synchron
Synchron muss ich dabei sagen
Hatte keiner DSL
Danke für den Sub
Sorry Leute
Massive Nice Subscriptions
Heute wieder
Bestimmt wieder
JST Lahnert
Agile Enjoyer
Sachsen Silver
Dankeschön
Weiß jemand was das für Racks sind
Ich kenn die Dinger
Da greift man mit dem Finger
Hier vorne rein
Also normalerweise
Ich kenn die Dinger
Ich hatte die auch schon mal im Rechenzentrum
Da greift man mit dem Finger hier unten in das Schlüsselloch rein
Drückt nach oben
Und dann springt
Und dann springt dieses Ding raus
Und man kann aufmachen
Das ist normalerweise nicht gedacht
Normalerweise ist es dafür gedacht glaube ich dass man ein Schloss da rein macht
Aber
An dem einen Standort wo wir diese Dinger hatten
Da war da kein Schloss drin
Da musstest du immer mit dem Finger hier in das Loch reingreifen
Und hochdrücken
Und dann ist es halt hier rausgesprungen
Ich vermute dass es hier auch so ist
Weil ich sehe keine
Na man erkennt es jetzt nicht so richtig
Es könnten auch
Es könnten auch wirklich Schlösser drin sein
Je nachdem was da gebraucht wird
Ja doch doch hier sieht man es
Da sind Schlösser drin
Die Version die ich kenne
War ähnliche Version
Aber es waren keine Schlösser eingebaut
Es war hier nur dieses Loch für Schlösser
Und da hat man hier mit dem Finger reingegriffen
Und musste nach oben drücken
Und dann hat sich hier die Verriegelung gelöst
Eigentlich ist das doch Scam
Die teilen sich doch die Netzwerkanbindung
Mit allen anderen Servern
Hä? Nein das ist den hier in Uplink
Viermal 100 Gigabit
Das ist quasi die Anbindung
In den
Backbone
Von tja weiß nicht
Inwieweit die das bis wohin die das noch
Selbst betreiben
Dann sind das doch gar keine 100 Gigabit
Pro Server
Nein es sind keine dedizierten
Anbindungen
Für den Server
Aber die werden dir das bestimmt auch nicht verkaufen
Keiner verkauft dir eine rein exklusiv
Keiner schon du kannst dir auch eigenes Glasfaser
Legen lassen das geht schon
Aber niemand verkauft dir
Wenn da 100 Gigabit
Oder was weiß ich
Das heißt nie
Das es exklusiv für dich ist
Also
Das ist damit nie gemeint
Das ist die Anbindung für den Backbone
Ich weiß nicht bis wohin sie es selbst machen
Weiter verteilt auch mit 100 Gigabit
Oder vielleicht auch nur mit 10 Gigabit
Je nachdem an welchen Schrank das geht
Und was da auch dann letztendlich an Geräten dran hängt
Und wir stehen jetzt einfach hier in einem dieser
Typischen Kaltgänge drin
Also unter mir kommt eben die kalte Luft raus
Und es geht dann hier durch
Die Server
Und das hier ist auch ein extrem interessantes
CLI Jumper
Ich würde interessieren
Wie warm es bei denen im Rechenzentrum ist
Und
So die letzten
10 Jahre
10 bis 15 Jahre
Geht eigentlich dahin
Dass man es im Rechenzentrum ein bisschen wärmer macht
Im Vergleich zu früher
Also
Wohin es früher 18 Grad waren
Nein, nein, nein
20 Grad ist das was die Klimaanlage ausspuckt
Das ist nicht unbedingt das es in dem Raum
20 Grad ist
Also zumindest
Wo es am Anfang drin war
Zumal es ja oftmals auch so ist
Dass du so eine Art Würfel da stehen hast
Mit
Dass du geschlossene Zonen
Im Rechenzentrum hast
Also dass du quasi
Einen Gang hast, wo die Server dann
Die warme Luft rausblasen
Und dann
Wird es
Quasi angesaugt und dann kommt
Kalte Luft von der anderen Seite
Je nachdem wie das aufgebaut ist
Aber der Trend ging dahin, dass tatsächlich wieder ein bisschen wärmer zu machen
Also dass man es nicht
Hardcore runterkühlt auf 18 Grad
Sondern vielleicht sogar schon ein bisschen mehr
Ich weiß nicht was da gerade so eine angesagte
Temperatur ist
Auch gefühlt sagt mir so irgendwas
Vielleicht 24 Grad
Weil
Sich wohl rausgestellt hat
Dass
Man sehr viel Geld damit sparen kann
Und
Dass die Kisten auch nicht
Nennenswert
Lebensdauer
Einbüßt
Also der Trend die letzten Jahre ging wieder hin
Die Rechenzentren ein bisschen wärmer zu machen
Also damals als ich meine Ausbildung noch gemacht habe
Da war das alles richtig runtergekühlt
Auf irgendwie 18 Grad
Da musstest du wirklich auch Jacken anziehen
Da drinne
War kalt, hat ein bisschen gezogen
Ohne Jacke
Die letzten Male wo ich dann im Rechenzentrum war
Bei uns war das alles eigentlich easy
Du konntest auch im T-Shirt rumlaufen
Hast jetzt vielleicht nicht geschwitzt aber
War jetzt nicht so unangenehm
Hattet ihr in eurem Rechenzentrum auch
Managebare PDUs?
Das ist eine gute Frage
Also wir hatten auf jeden Fall in Zentralen
Keyboard, Maus
Switch Zeugs über Netzwerkkabel
Du konntest dir quasi
Du hattest hinten so einen Technikraum
Und dann konntest dir dann quasi
Maus Tastatur
Anschließen und dann konntest du das patchen
Mit so einem Netzwerkkabel, das kam dann hinten in dem
In dem Raum raus
Wir hatten aber auch mehrere Wagen
Mit Tastatur und Monitor
Wo man im Zweifelsfall direkt an die Kiste dran konnte
Aber ob man
Strom Remote
Wirklich so hart ein- und ausschalten
Konnte, weiß ich nicht
Ist aber auch gar nicht wirklich
Notwendig gewesen
Weil
In der Regel konntest du den Server ein- und ausschalten
Über das Management Interface von der Kiste
Ja
In ganz seltenen Fällen hättest du theoretisch
Vielleicht auch so IP-Steckdosen mäßig was gebraucht
Aber
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern
Ob
Wir sowas hatten
Hier haben wir eigens designte
Gehäuse von IONOS
Denn, also es ist zwar 19 Zoll breite
Aber diese Gehäuse, die die verwenden
Sind komplett in-house designed
Denn, das sind so genannte
BTO-Produkte, das heißt
Jemand kann online diese Server
Konfigurieren und dann
Nach den eigenen Bedürfnissen
Entsprechend auswählen, also mal als Beispiel
Das was wir hier sehen können, so ein breites Ding
Ist eine Höheneinheit, also
Ungefähr so hoch, da kann man
Bis zu
4 normale HDDs reinpacken und
10 2,5 Zoll SSDs
Wenn man das mal überlegt von der Masse
Ja gut, das ist ja
Das Schöne ist, das sieht ja zu klein aus
Aber diese Racks sind ja auch
Nach hinten
Eine ganze Ecke, ich weiß nicht
Was werden diese Racks sein, 70, 80
Zentimeter oder so
Da hast du schon ordentlich
Platz nach hinten
Ja Moment, das ist die Breite
Das ist die Breite
Nach hinten, die Tiefe meine ich
70, 80 Zentimeter
Es gibt auch noch längere
Aber da hast du
Da hast du schon ordentlich Platz nach hinten
Ist halt die Frage
Ob die Server auch bis ganz nach hinten gehen
Aber es sah ja schon vorhin so aus
Wobei das waren glaube ich andere, die wir vorhin von hinten gesehen haben
Kennst du Stonit?
Das wird häufig Stream-Mode schaltbar
Das kenne ich
Das ist aber nichts
Was mit Strom
Also mit Leisten zu tun hätte
Das ist
Für Linux
Beziehungsweise für Unix Systeme
Mit dem du quasi
Hart andere Kisten ausschalten kannst
Oder abschießen kannst
Aber vielleicht kannst du das dann halt auch
Mit irgendeinem Call-Request auf eine
Managebare
Steckdosenleiste machen
Ich kenne das, ich kann mich aber nicht
Mehr dran erinnern, wann ich das das letzte Mal
Benutzt habe, das muss schon ganz schön lange her sein
Auf so eine kleine Höhe
Ist es schon enorm
Ist natürlich klar abhängig davon, was ist auf dem Mainboard
Verbaut, hat das Mainboard überhaupt genug
PC-Express-Ports, SATA-Anschlüsse
Wie auch immer
Das braucht dringend Stickstoffkühlung
Weil die Standardkonfiguration
Zum Beispiel von so einer Storage-Lösung
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der Fachbegriff dafür ist
Da hat man eben 4 HDDs drin
Und 2 SSDs
Aber das muss natürlich das Mainboard auch hergeben
Das alles von den Geräten her
Unterstützen zu können
Und ich glaube wir schauen uns jetzt einfach mal kurz online an
Wie man sowas
Konfigurieren könnte
Was man da auswählen kann
Und dann 3x
Auf so eine Konfiguration
So einen Umbau
Für die Konfiguration unserer
Servers gehen wir auf die IONOS
Dedicated Server Website und gehen hier
Weiter zu der Auswahl
Mich interessiert vor allem durch die Preis-Leistung
Ein AMD-Server und in der weiteren Auswahl
Sehen wir, dass entweder HDD
Oder NVMe-SSDs
Als Basis verwendet werden können
Diese Servers sind sogenannte BTO-Produkte
BTO bedeutet, dass diese Server
Im Kundenauftrag nach Bestellung und Wunsch
Erst gebaut werden
Den AR8-64 NVMe
Mit Ryzen 7 Pro 3700
Konfigurieren wir uns
Jetzt auf die maximale Ausbaustufe
Mit 128
Ordentlich
Aber ehrlich
3x
Oder 3x8T NVMe-SSD
27 GB
20 GB
Wie viele
Was ist ein AR8-64
64 Kerne
Oder was für was steht das 64
Also da bezahlst du
Wenn du bei den großen Cloud-Anbietern hingehst
Bei Microsoft oder Google
Für so eine ähnliche Kiste
Da wirst du wahrscheinlich
Mehr bezahlen
CentOS 7
MonkaS
Insgesamt 4 NVMe-SSD
Mit je 7,68 TB
Den Server
Den wir uns jetzt gerade online konfiguriert haben
Den haben wir jetzt hier
Denn es gibt immer so eine Art Basis-Konfiguration
Da sind die alle gleich
Die gibt es einmal als HDD oder einmal als SSD-Basis-Konfiguration
Und
Dann weiß Ionos
Der hier ist gerade frei
Und der wird dann für denjenigen
Der das konfiguriert hat schon mal reserviert
Und da der ja
Eine Custom-Konfiguration ist
Nehmen wir den jetzt raus
Ach die sind ja verhältnismäßig klein noch
Das geht ja
Voll klar
Mit
Und wir dürfen den jetzt umbauen
Also auch von der Tiefe her
Ist das gar nicht so
Die Standard-Konfiguration die wir jetzt rausgezogen haben
Liegt vor uns auf dem Tisch
Und die werden wir jetzt entsprechend upgraden
Denn wir haben hier aktuell
64 GB Rahmen drin
Und hier haben wir aktuell
In der Basis-Konfiguration
Zwei NVMe-SSDs
Ich frage mich wie sich das anhört wenn ein ganzes Rack Fanspin-up macht
Das ist laut
Das kann ich dir sagen
Denk mal dran
Komplett voll gebaut
Waren bei uns die wenigsten Racks
Also so krass
Server an Server gestapelt
Also wir hatten meistens die
Die Switcher oben
Und da war immer noch ein bisschen Platz
Aber ich hatte schon mal ein Rack
Mit glaube
Wie hoch sind das
8 Höhen Einheiten
Ich sag jetzt mal 6 Playcenter drinnen
Also ein volles Rack
Voll mit Playcentern
Wenn das angeht
Das
Ich meine du schaltest ja meistens nicht das Rack
Irgendwie an einem Schalter ein und aus
Das alles gleichzeitig angeht
Aber wenn du da Playcenter eingebaut hast
Schließ sie an und drück sie dann alle an
Die booten ja auch relativ lang
Für ihr Management Interface
Die haben dann am Anfang immer 4-5 Minuten
Wo volle Pulle die Lüfter sind
Atheno danke für den Sub
Und wenn du da die Dinger nacheinander einschaltest
Du hast ein paar Minuten über Lappen
So 6 Playcenter, volle Pulle die Lüfter
Das ist schon so ein halbes Flugzeug
Was dir da entgegen pustet
Mit jeweils 960 GB
Die werden wir jetzt erstmal upgraden
Man sieht auch hier so ein bisschen den internen Aufbau
Das ich gerade schon angesprochen hatte
An den Haken hier oben
Ja Playcenter ist für mich halt
Von der Lüfterlautstärke
Und der Lüfter
Des Luftdurchsatzes
So das heftigste was ich kenne
Könnte man eben
Weitere SSDs anbringen
Man ist davon ja aber ein bisschen weg gekommen
Das benutzt man heute selten
Und wir machen das jetzt einfach mal
Wie man das machen würde
Das heißt vorne die Schraube raus
Die ich jetzt erstmal fallen lassen
Und hinten natürlich
Die Strom und Datenversorgung weg
Weil das sind U2 SSDs
Das sind Geoxia SSDs
Und wie man sehen kann
Das unterscheidet sich auch
Drastisch von einer normalen Consumer SSD
Mal abgesehen davon
Das die ein U2 Interface hat
Also das ist keine SATA SSD
Das ist quasi PCI Express oder so
Direkt an
PCI Express als Kabel
PCI Express SSD über Kabel
Die U2
Die hat hier Löcher an der Seite
Und dadurch ist die SSD eben
Sehr gut belüftet
Was eine normale Consumer SSD nicht ist
Weil die sind in der Regel vollständig geschlossen
Die 2 960 GB SSDs habe ich jetzt ausgebaut
Und die ersetzen wir jetzt mit
4 7,68 TB SSDs
Das hätte ich auch gerne in meinem NAS
Die kommen dann wieder
Hier rein entsprechend in diesen NASen
Schön nebeneinander
Natürlich müssen die vorne noch festgeschraubt werden
Ich leg die jetzt aber erstmal so kurz rein
Um euch einfach schnell zu zeigen
Das haben sie aber schön gemacht
Also da merkst du halt
Dass die das professionell machen
Das ist halt genau darauf ausgelegt
Dass du sowas schnell und zackig
Und möglichst problemlos
Einbauen kannst
Easy verkabeln kannst
Dir nicht irgendwie die Finger wehtust
Nicht irgendwie einen Kopfstand machen musst
Bis du es eingebaut hast
Dann merkst du das
Du kannst damit Geld verdienen
Ich zeig euch jetzt
Wie schnell und einfach man das hier einbauen kann
Hinten müsste dann die U2 Verbindung noch ran
Vorne
Wird es
Verschraubt
Und so ist dann wirklich innerhalb von
Absolut wenigen Sekunden der Umbau möglich
Von zum Beispiel 2 x 960 GB
Auf dann letztendlich hier
Aber Leute es ist auch kein 1 Euro Server
Den man hier sieht
Hier haben wir jetzt das Herzstück von diesem Server
Hier haben wir natürlich das Mainboard
Mit CPU drauf
Da haben wir einen Ryzen 7 3700 Pro
Und hier oben seht ihr das drüber
Ist diese kleine Abdeckung
Und diese Abdeckung
Das ist so Airflow mäßig
Ihr seht
Die ist einfach natürlich in erster Linie dafür da
Dass die Luft richtig durch den Server durchgeleitet wird
Richtig durch den Kühler durch
Und natürlich auch über den Rahmen drüber
Dass alle Komponenten richtig gekühlt werden
Und diese kleine Luft Light Abdeckung
Die ist aus PET
PET kennt ihr von Kunststoffflaschen
Und das ist tatsächlich
Eine recycelte Flasche
Als einziges
Wie viel würde so ein Server
In Einzelteilen kosten?
Eine recycelte Plastikflasche
Aber alleine schon die 7 TB
SSDs dürften schweinend teuer sein
In der heutigen Zeit auf jeden Fall
Sehr cooles Feature
Also die SSDs sind teurer als der Server
Also der Server ist billiger als die SSDs
Der Rest von diesem Ding
Ist komplett aus Stahl
Was ja auch gut ist
Das kann man komplett wiederverwerten
Warum sind eigentlich alle Rechenzentren
Immer mit diesen grauen Bodenplatten?
Es ist immer exakt
Der gleiche Farbton
Auch diese komischen Flecken
Die da drauf sind
Das sieht überall genauso aus
Was ja auch gut ist
Das kann man komplett wiederverwerten
Das ist trotzdem
Ein Custom Design
Für IONOS
Leicht angepasst
Hat auch einen eigenen Namen
Vielleicht gibt es die echt nur von einem Anbieter
Man hat zwar hier 2 M.2 Sorts
An der Seite
Trotzdem verwenden die
Hier diese Adapterkarte
Die geht von 16 PCIe auf 4x4
Das heißt wir haben hier diese U2 Kabel dran
Das sind die 2 Kabel die bereits schon vorinstalliert waren
Das sieht ein bisschen aus
Wie es es bei AliExpress für meiner früher gab
Nur etwas professioneller
Den 2 ursprünglichen SSDs
Und von den 4 die wir reingeschickt haben
Werden jetzt aktuell noch 2 nicht angeschlossen
Das heißt wir müssen noch mal 2 weitere Kabel verlegen
An diese beiden weiteren U2 Anschlüsse
Vom Luftstrom
Ansonsten ist es so
Ihr seht hier vorne sind auch diese kleinen Lüfter
Und die sorgen eben dafür
Das nicht nur die Festplatten und SSDs ausreichend gekühlt werden
Sondern gleichzeitig auch eben CPU
Arbeitsspeicher, Spannungswandler
Chipsatz und so weiter
Also die Luftrichtung ist eben hier so durch
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich vermutet
Hier unten drunter ist eine RAID Karte
Sieht ein bisschen so aus
Von der Posi und vom Kühler her
Muss aber nicht sein
Die Priorität natürlich erstmal auf den Laufwerken vorne liegt
Weil die auch die geringste Abwärme haben
Und dann geht das ganze
Am Ende durch die CPU
Und hinten wieder raus
Wie gerade schon angesprochen haben wir in der Grundkonfiguration
Hier 64 GB RAM drin
Wir hatten aber ja gerade online
128 GB RAM
Konfiguriert
Und dementsprechend müssen wir jetzt hier den Arbeitsspeicher noch wechseln
Da sei auch gesagt
Klar natürlich normalerweise macht das hier
Ein professioneller Techniker
Der macht das dann auch mit ESD Band
Aber es ist ja mein Server
Und bei meinem Server ist es dann auch nicht so schlimm
Wir haben doch bei diesem PC Aufbau Video gelernt
Dass es reicht
Wenn man sich
Das Band nur um den Arm macht
Das reicht dann schon
Einfach um den Arm
So als Armband
Die RAM Riegel ein bisschen anders
Ich sag mal konventioneller einbauen
Da gab es doch dieses Weiß PC Aufbau Video
Kennt das noch jemand?
So erstmal
So ein ESD Armband anziehen
Und dann hat das nirgendswo angeschlossen
Deswegen nehme ich mir jetzt hier
Viermal 32 GB Riegel
Ach
Nicht Verge war das
Verge genau
Muss mich aber auch mal outen
Ich habe hier so ein
Band liegen
Ich benutze das auch nie
Ich greife immer einmal an die Heizung
Bevor ich irgendwas mache
Das reicht
Damit ich dann gleich am Ende auch
Meine versprochenen 128 GB bekomme
Jetzt natürlich fertig verkabeln
Wie gesagt die SSDs
Klappe wieder zu reinschieben
Um nochmal zu dem Thema Kühlung zurück zu kommen
Gerade hier seht ihr neben mir
Stehe ich neben Filtern und da kommt schöne kalte Luft raus
Denn das ist die
Ansaugung von draußen
Das heißt hier dahinter ist im Prinzip die Außenwelt
Das heißt da kann die kalte Luft rein
Weil draußen ist es gerade ein bisschen kühler
Und die Luft wird hier durch diesen
Gang wo wir gerade drin stehen
Wird hier eingesaugt und dann seht ihr hier oben
Diese Lüftungsklappen
Und durch diese Lüftungsklappen geht die Luft dann
Durch und hier innen drin
Sitzen
Wie ihr es im PC-Wasserkühlungsbereich kennt
Radiatoren
Durch diese Radiatoren strömt die Luft durch
Und je nachdem was das für Klimaverhältnisse sind
Passiert gegebenenfalls gar nichts
Also zum Beispiel heute ist es ein bisschen kühler draußen
Da kann einfach nur mit der Luft von außen gekühlt werden
Das heißt die kalte Luft geht hier rein
Geht hier durch und wird dann
Also hier drin auch nochmal gefiltert
Das sind nochmal extra Filter
Und geht dann zu den Kaltgängen
Von den Servern wo wir gerade drin standen
Wo dann die Luft in der Regel zwischen 16 und
18 Grad Celsius kalt
Dann in den Kaltgang unten reinkommt
Und dann ist es natürlich davon abhängig
Wie warm oder wie kalt ist es draußen
Weil wenn es draußen vielleicht mal 35 Grad im Sommer hat
Dann kann man mit dieser Luft von außen
Natürlich nichts mehr anfangen
Und dann ist es so, dass diese Radiatoren
Die da drin sind
Die werden dann mit kaltem Wasser durchströmt
Und das Wasser wird außen
Durch die Klimaanlage dann heruntergekühlt
Wenn es außen im Sommer
Sehr sehr warm ist
Wenn es klimatisch
Dann gibt es auch noch
Die geschlossene Freiluftkühlung
Da ist es dann so, dass die Luft hier drin
In dem Rechenzentrum gehalten wird
Das heißt die Klappen von außen werden zugemacht
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie vom Staubsauger
Das dachte ich mir auch gerade
Und die Luft im Rechenzentrum zirkuliert
Geht also immer wieder durch diese Radiatoren durch
Und die Radiatoren werden dann einfach nur
Durch die kalte Außenluft gekühlt
Das heißt es gibt im Prinzip drei Kühlwege
Einfach nur mit der kalten Außenluft
Von außen, so wie es heute der Fall ist
Das ist natürlich der effizienteste und auch günstigste Weg
Dann gibt es noch den zweiten Fall
Wo auch noch mit der kalten Außenluft gekühlt wird
Aber das durch die Radiatoren geht
Die dann heruntergekühlt werden
Das kann zum Beispiel der Fall sein
Okay, das juckt mich jetzt nicht so
Das finde ich noch ganz interessant
Ich muss mal ein bisschen vorskippen
Weil, bad good time
Sollte es doch mal zum Brand kommen
Dann gibt es natürlich auch ein Löschsystem
Das ist unter dieser Leitung standen
Und das kommt dann gegebenenfalls
Mich würde interessieren, wie viel Zeit die Leute haben
Zu flüchten
Man muss aber dazu sagen, dass das was wir hier sehen
Ist nur für die IT-Systeme
Also das unten in dem anderen Raum
Da gibt es noch mal mehrere Räume
Wo mehrere von diesen großen Stickstoffflaschen stehen
Und die sind gefüllt mit 200 Bar
Das heißt
Mehr Views hat das nicht
Wenn das mal auslöst, dann geht es auch richtig ab
Weil natürlich auch sichergestellt werden muss
Dass der ganze Stickstoff sich komplett
Dann in dem Rechenzentrum
Oder in den betroffenen Gebieten verteilen kann
Sinn davon ist natürlich, weil Stickstoff ist sowieso in der Luft
Das heißt, es ist erstmal kein
Gefährliches Gas oder sowas
Aber man versucht dadurch natürlich
Den Sauerstoff zu verdrängen
Dass wenn es irgendwo brennt
Man den Brand dann erstickt
Oder wenn es einfach ein Schweelbrand ist
Dass der Brand gar nicht erst entsteht
Und da eignet sich natürlich Stickstoff sehr gut
Und ja, wenn es dann
Nicht detektiert wird, dann kann das auslösen
Und dann wird dann eben in den Räumen überall
Dieser Stickstoff verteilt, das dann
Den Brand gegebenenfalls gelöscht
Wie viel Zeit hast du zu flüchten?
Dafür gibt es dann auch zwei
Also wir haben hier Hauptbatterie und hier steht Reservebatterie drauf
Das heißt, auch wenn so ein System hier auslöst
Dann kann man auch sagen
Vielleicht fängt es an
Einen wunderschönen Blick über Berlin
Das Wasser runter zu kühlen
Das Wasser läuft dann wieder unten runter
Damit sind wir auch durch
Mit unserem kurzen Rechenzentren-Tour-Video
Hier von IONOS in Berlin
Haben wir sehr viel Spaß gemacht
Vor allem, weil es auch direkt in Berlin ist
Weil ich seit 15 Jahren IONOS-Kunde bin
Ist es auch gut möglich, dass meine Sachen hier auch irgendwo
Auf einem Server laufen
Deswegen vielen Dank nochmal an IONOS, dass wir hier sein durften
Dass wir euch zeigen durften, wie dieses Rechenzentrum hier aussieht
Wenn ihr euch auch für die BTO-Produkte
Von IONOS interessiert
Also so einen Server, den man eben
An seine eigenen Bedürfnisse anpassen kann
Gerade was Arbeitsspeicher, was NVMe, was HDD betrifft
Dann findet ihr die Links dazu
Auf jeden Fall auch unten in der Beschreibung
Das könnt ihr euch sehr sehr gerne anschauen
Ansonsten bedanke ich mich für eure Aufmerksamkeit
Dass ihr immer wieder dabei wart
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal
Nice, sind wir ja pünktlich fertig
Was ist das hier?
Warum kriege ich das empfohlen?
Dachte ich kriege vielleicht noch mehr
Mehr empfohlen
Ey du
Youtube hat festgestellt
Ich